from a young age i've always found the
interest in really
paving my own path from the beginning
whether that was learning
how the web works and learning how to
rank companies organically
and then now into medley i've always
been curious about how to solve
problems and that's partly where medley
has come up and why we decided to go
after this
this big problem
my name is chirag kulkarni and i'm the
co-founder and the chief marketing
officer of medley
medley is a digital pharmacy that offers
same-day
medication delivery so instead of having
to go into the pharmacy
wait in line having to deal with all the
stock medications
not having technology built what we've
done is we've built the pharmacy from
the ground up
and imagined what does an experience
look like when you bundle
technology logistics and a bundling of
these consumer services to deliver
superior pharmacy services it makes
sense to innovate on this existing model
and build something that is able to
scale especially with the rise of
e-commerce
the american dream to me is being able
to make a difference
and and making sure that regardless of
where you've come from
you have the ability to make an impact
on someone's life
whether it's one person or it's millions
of people my parents came to this
country
with few dollars in their pocket and
really were able to build
not only a great life for themselves but
for
myself and my sibling and i think just
seeing them
and through their struggles you know i
find it very lucky and find myself very
fortunate
that i can work on challenging problems
you know such as
the medication and the pharmacy business
and and really
be able to impact people at the ground
level every single day
one thing i would say to people that are
maybe hitting roadblocks is
is really as simple as putting one foot
in front of the other that you don't
have to have all the answers
on day one but the important thing is to
surround yourself by people that are
much smarter than you
and also work every day and just get one
percent better and at the end of the day
by doing that you end up reaching closer
and closer towards
challenging goals and being able to
actually realize them
you